so I just got to my dressing room and
found this actual olive branch this
means so much to me Taylor Swift posted
that to Instagram Tuesday it's a gift
from Katy Perry seemingly ending the bad
blood between them while the note is not
fully legible we managed to decipher
some of Katie's message quote hey old
friend
I've been doing some reflecting on past
miscommunications and the feelings
between us I really want to clear the
air I'm deeply sorry this is a big deal
the ladies haven't been friends in years
there was speculation Katy tried to
sabotage Taylor's red tour there were
suspicious sub tweets dance thought it
was more than a coincidence when Taylor
released her music to streaming services
on the day Katy's last album dropped and
yes there were songs
[Music]
swish swish fish Katie's apology comes
the same day Taylor is set to kick off
her massive reputation stadium tour on
the way to the first show going to the
stadium I'm gonna go say hi to Charlie
I'm gonna go say hi to Camilla I'm so
excited I'm so excited I'm so excited
now we're just ready for a collab
between Taylor and Katy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]